and let me just make sure I have this
right as I recall there was a photograph
taken during the production of Batman
versus super
and one of the crew guys had a painting
of Thomas Wayne bat Bruce Wayne's father
and it looked a little bit like Javier
Bardem because you look almost identical
right here Bardem so you at that time
you didn't say yes you didn't say no but
now I've learned that if there's some
comic series where Thomas Wayne is a
Batman they'll get Batman dad Batman or
something yeah are you going a paradox
universe Batman
last point Batman in the flash movie
let's go back to that
I don't think you have no know I don't
know anything you don't know any no I
don't you would know if you weren't
playing him right why really I don't
know anything you know that DCE has a
lot of throw see I'm not working with DC
I've worked with DC oh yeah I did that
Superman Batman thing I was in Watchmen
[Applause]
I wasn't watching okay alright effect
you showed the very first picture of me
as the comedian that's right show you
have you've done a lot of work for this
Morgan universe those graphic novels on
the toilet a million times yeah yeah
well okay so this I think we got a
little something out of you
hey everybody a lot of you been asking
me to do a flashpoint video because
that's going to be the flash movie no
matter what but there's a lot of talk
behind the scenes about how changes
might be made to the movie depending on
what happens to the Justice League movie
when it comes out in a couple weeks so
there is still Justice League take a
giveaway stuff happening I'll explain at
the end of the video but the big thing
with Jeffrey Dean Morgan Thomas Wayne
Batman if you've never read the
flashpoint comic or you've never seen
the animated movie which is actually a
pretty faithful adaptation of the comic
book story basically the flash goes back
changes time tries to save his mother
from being killed by the reverse-flash
but learns that it creates this paradox
where everything has gone [ __ ] they did
a version of it on the TV show so
basically the idea is is that the flash
messing with time travel is a terrible
idea
and he's already done it in Batman V
Superman like we saw Ezra Miller flash
come back to talk to our Bruce Wayne to
say that Lois is the key so very clearly
they were setting something up for
Justice League already so it sounds like
they had ideas to do a version of
flashpoint regardless of whether or not
they would call it that but before they
announced a legit flash flashpoint movie
I was just assuming that they were going
to handle all that in the Justice League
movie and it would be Ben Affleck's
Batman the
old time he's getting this horrible
vision of a future where Superman has
turned against them so there were a lot
of rumors that there was stuff like that
happening in Justice League so it's like
okay this is their version of flashpoint
but the problem with that is that sort
of throws out the core concepts of
flashpoint in the time-travel is bad and
very clearly the bad thing was already
happening and the flash went back to
make it a good thing by having Batman go
by and Lois Lane and bring the Justice
League together but they announced the
flashpoint movie then you get in a
thomas wayne territory so that opens up
all kinds of possibilities like they say
that their movie strategy is changing
just a little bit they won't try to
overlap the movies quite as much as they
have in the past so there is a version
of flashpoint that they could have done
in the flash movie that didn't quite
affect everything in such a broad way
because in the comic book version it
really is a Justice League story with
all the Justice League characters in the
flashpoint timeline everybody's trying
to kill each other it almost leads to
the extinction of the entire human race
but the reason why Jeffrey Dean Morgan
is having so much fun with this is one
because he reads comics he knows exactly
what goes on with Thomas Wayne during
the flashpoint storyline even though
he's sort of being tongue-in-cheek and
he's winking at the camera a little bit
like I don't know what you're talking
about
wink you know smile like yeah very
clearly they've had conversations behind
the scenes about this you just have to
remember that the flashpoint movie is
still a couple years away and they
haven't completely settled on what
that's going to be they're probably
still tinkering with the script and a
lot of it depends on how the Justice
League movie does you may have seen all
the news reports the last couple of days
saying that the flashpoint movie depends
on how well Justice Li does financially
what that would mean is is that it just
determines the version of flashpoint
that they go with what the story is
going to be if they want to they can
edit anything they want from previous
movies so a really good example of that
is they've already retconned Wonder
Woman's character just a little bit
after Batman vs Superman there was this
idea that she had abandoned humanity for
about a hundred years or so and then
she's inspired to take the mantle back
up when all that craziness happened with
doomsday so when they got to the
woman movie they made a minor change to
her character in that she never
abandoned humanity we realize that
actually there is no way that one a
woman will ever give up on mankind the
reason why she left the island was
because she wanted to make their life
better and safer that they're there
called they are her calling so I'm
giving you a very honest answer but it
was sometimes you know in a creative
process you establish something that is
not necessarily the right decision but
then you can always correct it and
changes so Wonder Woman so when you hear
her say that it doesn't sound like that
big of a change for the character it's
not something you would see on screen
but it represents some core conceits of
her character and where she's coming
from it kind of makes her seem like less
of an [ __ ] when we get to present day
because you're like wait a minute
there were a bunch of wars after World
War one wouldn't she come back to help
for those two so if they do make changes
to their other Justice League characters
during flashpoint I think it'll be
limited to that like they'll make them
seem like less of an [ __ ] when you
get to the new timeline whatever that
looks like but everybody's been
wondering what about the second Justice
League movie they said they're already
working on a script and I genuinely
think they have an idea for a
straight-up Justice League sequel but
there is a rumor that they might just
turn the flashpoint movie into that
Justice League sequel and include more
characters that would mean making it a
much bigger film and that's why you're
hearing all that talk about Warner
Brothers waiting to see how the Justice
League movie does financially before
they make any hard decisions about what
that flashpoint movie is going to be so
if you've never seen jeffrey dean morgan
play negan or the comedian or any of
those other characters honestly even
though i think he could do an amazing
thomas wayne batman i think it's a very
dark version of the character and
everything we've seen from behind the
scenes the stuff that geoff johns has
said publicly makes it sound like
they're pivoting away from really dark
movies they're trying to be more hopeful
so if we do see Thomas Wayne Batman
however faithful to the comic book story
they are I think it'll be a relatively
minimal amount of Thomas Wayne Batman I
think if they were to include gal gadot
as Wonder Woman in that movie
they've been pivoting towards Wonder
Woman recently so much honestly they
include her in that movie I think they
spend more time focused on her so
regardless of how much Jeffrey Dean
Morgan Thomas Wayne Batman you see
you're just spending more time on screen
with those characters so let me know in
the comments do you want to see them use
Thomas Wayne Batman in the movie and do
you want them to turn it into a
full-blown Justice League movie because
for instance the animated movie is
literally called Justice League
flashpoint they just started promoting a
whole bunch of Batman stuff for Justice
League so let me know if you want me to
do another video for all that stuff
because there's a little bit of new
footage but there was a really big Star
Wars the last Jedi interview over the
weekend where kylo Ren revealed some big
details about the characters especially
raised backstory so because they also
dropped a new TV trailer I'll probably
do a video for that next there's a new
round of that Justice League take a
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video congratulations to last
week's giveaway winner skull jockey
please private message me so I can get
your contact details you can click here
to learn all about the Shazam of the
Justice League universe here they just
cast the actor and you can click here
for brand new flash thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight